stromausfall in großen teilen der erde
satelliten fallen aus und stürzte ab von
einem auf den anderen tag wären
millionen und abermillionen elektrischer
geräte einfach so kaputt
dieses szenarios unser planet am 23 juli
2012 nur haarscharf entgangen jetzt ein
klick zum science und fiction
haben 23 juli 2012 geschah etwas mit dem
forscher eigentlich nur alle paar
hundert jahre rechnen und über die
konsequenzen
und wie wir uns dagegen schützen können
hatte sich bis dato eigentlich kaum
jemand gedanken gemacht
eine riesige plasma eruption löst du
dich von der sonne richtung erde
die hatte gott sei dank gerade das
zielgebiet verlassen und der sturm
verfehlte die erde nur knapp ansonsten
wäre das passiert was schon einmal 859
geschah damals traf uns ein riesiger
sonnensturm bis an den äquator waren
polarlichter zu sehen die telegrafen
leitung sprühten funken und das
telegrafen netz wurde damals massiv
gestört allerdings gab es da von damals
leben nicht 200.000 kilometer es war das
carrington ereignis der britische
astronom richard caring hatte es damals
entdeckt die konsequenzen
heute wären viel schlimmer hätte uns der
getroffen würden wir heute immer noch
die schäden beseitigen sagt daniel
becker von der university of colorado
über den sonnensturm 2012 auf 2
billionen dollar wird der mögliche
schaden geschätzt
eine der folgenreichsten
naturkatastrophen die die erde jemals
erlebt hätte und das nur weil wir heute
von der elektrizität abhängig sind
dabei ist ein sonnensturm an sich ganz
harmlos es ist eine eruption auf der
sonnenoberfläche bei der magnetisches
plasma in den weltraum geschleudert wird
elektronen und protonen trifft dieses
plasma die erde wird das magnetfeld
gestaucht und kosmische strahlung trifft
die atmosphäre und sogar tiefere
schichten wunderschöne polarlichter sind
sogar am äquator zu sehen
durch die moderne technik von der unser
leben überall auf unserem planeten
abhängt sind wir allerdings verwundbar
ein solches ereignis stört unser ganzes
elektrisches netzwerk das fängt bei den
gps satelliten an hier stören die von
der sonne ausgeworfenen elektrisch
geladenen teilchen direkt die satelliten
und unsere navis spielen verrückt am
boden werden durch das zusammen
quetschen des magnetfeldes riesige
ströme induziert die die elektrischen
geräte
zerstören flächendeckend ganze regionen
können durch einen sonnensturm
lahmgelegt werden
1989 passierte genau das in der
kanadischen region quebec dabei dieser
sonnensturm noch einigermaßen harmlos
und trotzdem 90 sekunden nach dem
aufschlag diese sonnensturms brach ein
komplettes stromnetz zusammen neun
stunden lang war die region lahmgelegt
der schaden wird auf hunderte millionen
dollar geschätzt und gut dass die region
mit strom aus wasserkraft versorgt wird
wäre ein kernkraftwerk betroffen gewesen
hätten die folgen katastrophal sein
können
wissenschaftler wie becker fordern jetzt
bessere sicherheitsmaßnahmen gegen
solche sonnenstürme denn es gilt
inzwischen als sicher dass ein heftiger
sonnensturm schon bald die erde treffen
könnte
geplant ist jetzt ein ring aus kleinen
satelliten groß die brotdosen rund um
die sonne
der als frühwarnsystem dienen soll und
gleichzeitig können mit diesem kleinen
satelliten neue erkenntnisse über das
magnetfeld der sonne gewonnen werden
neue erkenntnisse gibt es übrigens
alliance in unserem sonnensystem die
wahrscheinlichkeit auf anderen planeten
direkt in unserer nachbarschaft
organismen zu finden ist gestiegen
hier klicken für dieses video und
täglich neue wissenschafts news gibt es
im block und in der app dafür
hier klicken allerdings natürlich auch
in der video beschreibung und was meint
ihr
unterschätzen wir die risiken wenn wir
moderne technologien nutzen oder können
wir uns in sicherheit wiegen diskutiert
es mit mir in den kommentaren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt kann